what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters in all of comics and in
today's video we're gonna be talking
about a pretty recent addition to the
marvel universe but one that is
definitely one of the most powerful
characters introduced in recent memory
the black winter now the black winter
was created by donnie cates and first
appeared in silver surfer black number
four in 2019 or at least that's the
first time the black winter is mentioned
so silver surfer black is a pretty wild
story with a silver surfer sent
basically back to the beginning of time
where he encounters null the god of the
symbiotes in order to kill null he
basically has to manifest a new star
into being which causes him to have to
expend all the remaining power cosmic at
his disposal of course nola's not
destroyed he's just temporarily defeated
he then encounters a young ego the
living planet that has a foreign object
lodged into his core and after
journeying the ego's core to retrieve
the object the surfer discovers that
mysterious object is the incubator of
gallum the last survivor of the sixth
iteration of the marvel universe that
would eventually become galactus i mean
at this point i should probably explain
that the current marvel universe that we
see in comics being published by marvel
right now is the eighth version of the
marvel universe so it's been destroyed
and rebuilt multiple times and so
galactus had originated as gallon in the
sixth universe and he was basically a
scientist and he knew a lot of stuff you
know gallon knew all kinds of things and
the question has to be asked right how
did this guy know so much stuff well
i'll see exactly how he knew so much
stuff he had skillshare yes he did this
video is sponsored by skillshare so
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
where you can explore new skills develop
existing interests and get lost in
creativity now my favorite class of the
moment is by john logan marcino which is
called how to make a podcast plan record
and launch with success because i'm
working on a super secret project behind
the scenes and over the course of this i
have learned seemingly everything there
is that you need to know about how to
launch a podcast it quite literally
lives up to its name
because i haven't really been super
knowledgeable about podcasts but if
you're in the market to learn how to
create a podcast then courses like this
are perfect for you guys so the first
1000 of you all who click the link in
the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare so you can
start exploring your creativity today
and you can make 2022 a year of new
learning growth and connection through
creativity
but back to our video knowing that the
destruction that galactus would
eventually cause in the billions of
lives that would be lost to satisfy his
hunger the silver surfer ultimately
decided that he was going to destroy the
incubator before galactus could even be
born but he stopped from doing so by
watching the watcher who explains that
galactus must exist to maintain the
balance in the universe so instead of
killing galactus the surfer tries to
read the mind of gallon who's basically
asleep inside the incubator and he sees
the destruction of galactus reality the
sixth version of the marvel universe and
he calls the force responsible for this
destruction the black winter so the
first time we even hear of the black
winter we know that it is responsible
for the destruction of an entire
universe and the trillions of souls
contained within now the next time we
hear of the black winter is in the first
issue of donnie kate's and nick klein's
legendary thor run which is just
freaking phenomenal if you're not
reading it right now which began in
2020. now this takes place after thor
has succeeded his father odin to the
throne and rules asgard as its all
father not long into the issue galactus
quite literally falls from the sky and
crashes into asgard justice thor is
about to smash his face in with his
hammer of course galactus tells thor
that he came to ask for his help because
something he calls the star plague the
great black winter was coming now with
galactus is coming asgard was blanketed
with a constant blizzard and idris so
the life tree actually began to die and
so asgard is then visited by the silver
surfer who tells for what the black
winter is and that is the entity that
destroyed galactus universe and also
explains that the black winter serves as
a very similar role to galactus himself
the difference however is that while
galactus feeds on planets the black
winter feeds on entire realities and the
galactus was the only one who had ever
survived an attack from the black winter
now thor and silver surfer then devise a
plan to accompany galactus to five
planets that the surfer had hidden from
him for years because if galactus had
consumed them he would become more
powerful than anybody could have
imagined and so when they tell galactus
their plan we learn an additional power
that the black winter possesses which is
that when someone gazes into the black
winter they see their true death and
furthermore that galactus himself has
gazed into the black winter twice now
the first time he saw the destruction of
his reality the second time he saw thor
so he basically says that he and thor
will defeat the black winter together
and makes thor his herald of thunder
which was awesome creating arguably the
most powerful version of flor that we've
seen due to the fact that he not only
has access to the thor force as the
all-father of asgard but has also been
imbued with a power cosmic so really
this video is almost like taking two
beyond omega level characters in one
episode but following this we see the
black winter targeting a universe that
looks suspiciously similar to the dc
universe given that there is a building
that looks like the daily planet and the
superheroes that are obviously supposed
to be the justice league described as
sun god a god of emerald light a god of
dark and god of the ocean and a god of
plot armor but their combined efforts
are not enough to stop the black winter
from basically devouring their reality
now when it's done with the dc universe
the black winter sets its sights on the
marvel universe where thor and galactus
are traveling the cosmos in search of
the planets galactus needs to devour to
face the black winter now the first of
these planets which is called clips
turns out to be inhabited and thor
manages to get its inhabitants to safety
before galactus consumes it the next
planet they go to is uninhabited thor's
able to evacuate the third one and the
sentient core of the fourth planet
willingly gives its life to fuel
galactus in defense of the universe and
so the inhabitants of the fifth planet
called cairo refuse to be evacuated and
before thor can convince them galactus
just starts consuming their planet
because a black winter has arrived in
the marvel universe and he basically
needs to plant his power immediately so
thor unleashes a blast from mjolnir and
keep in mind he's also in possession of
the power cosmic at this point but it
only delays the black winter by 14
seconds which just shows us how insanely
powerful the black winter is now thor
and galactus battle this thing but it's
not long before the entity turns its
attention to thor with the goal of
showing him how he will die now he shows
thor all of the enemies that he's faced
over the years gore the godbutcher loki
man gog sorter pretty much any thor
villain you can think of but thor
summons all of his power in one final
god blast in a desperate attempt to hurt
the black winter and the blast has been
said to have made the black winter bleed
although it doesn't seem to do much
damage now when the black winter tells
thor he will show him the way his
universe ends and shows him himself as
he appears after becoming galactus
herald he then reveals the true purpose
that brought him to the marvel universe
in the first place he's not really there
to destroy the universe but to collect
his herald galactus so yeah we learned
that galactus was spared by the black
winter and the black winter is
responsible for his transformation from
gallon of tah and to galactus because
his purpose is to serve as his herald of
the black winter and so we know that any
entity that's able to have galactus
serve as his herald has to be insanely
powerful which really begs the question
how would franklin richards fare because
technically during hickman's fantastic
four run franklin richards turn galactus
into his own herald but once thor finds
out that galactus has been using him as
a pawn he's furious and then attacks him
now despite the fact that galactus is
more powerful than he'd ever been thanks
to the energy from the planets he
consumed thor is able to topple him with
a blast from mjolnir and then things get
really crazy as thor is actually able to
steal galactus power and then pronounce
his judgment on him for the destruction
he'd caused and uses the power he'd
taken to strike galactus down so when i
say this is arguably the strongest
version of thor that we've seen i was
not exaggerating but that's not even the
most impressive thing that we see thor
do here when the black winter tries to
take galactus with him thor refuses and
literally turns galactus into a bomb
that releases the entirety of the power
cosmic and the energy of all the planets
galactus had devoured and destroys the
black winter itself so yeah you guys
really get two beyond omega level
characters in one in this video but it's
kind of impossible to explain one of
them without the other you know what i
mean so i figured i would just make this
video by explaining both the black
winter and thor at the same time but
thank you guys for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and i will catch
you all later
peace